ciao a tutti abbiamo tenuti su aids
oggi il tema halloween e cioè cosa sente
male le zucche e poi i mostri di zombie
e poi cosa si fa ad halloween si va in
giro a dire dolcetto scherzetto
quindi se i dolcetti team anche perché
effetti ovviamente invitare benissimo
perché sa che potremo senza fatto prima
della gara però a volte non ti capita il
cibo ti cacciano scazzetta ci vuole
quindi ci siamo tim roth e di blu
fate il tifo o particolato fortin bruno
presente una collana da vampira collo
tagliati lasciato impellente potete
vedere altri di iolo technologies cui
cambiano le cose che devo con il cibo
che tipo di cane che vorreste vedere con
le classi sono scarti nuovo dietro lo
stato
3 2 1 ma com'è che si strutturino rossi
a questa cosa si firma con i gatti
queste sono pochissimi trovato questi
biscotti in kruger inglese o il succo la
tv a forma di zucca
io dicevo che c'era qualcosa che non
andava bene questi droni rico unione un
provino al cioccolato che loro tasche
[Musica]
mi piace è una piccola pesca talotti
l'assetto d'agrò potrebbe essere un
pochino pettino e roberto mania
cominciamo molto molle volo giovani ai
cioccolatini a forma di zucca per conto
suo interno molto da zucchero pino est
accatastato tanti non ci posso credere
che sia stata proprio per questi siano
vuote ma la palla dialogo in zuccheri a
talla prossimo round
ok
come dice dire tutto e tenerlo per
cambiarlo bello stile trovare il cibo da
piero scambi di cioccolato ma lo tengo
32 ora lo scherzetto qualcosa questa
collina campanile sono chi mi sembrano
perfetti io invece lo vediamo ma che è
stato più bello dentro cioccolato si
conta solo su presidente tutto il
cognato carmen è per tutti dentro
se non avete visto il nostro amico in
cui assaggiano tutti fismic dialoghi
dopo questo video andato il federatore
ai o una scatola con i biscotti di
cioccolato
[Musica]
un po se eravamo il primo basta quando
tiratore mostre bagni moderati alcuni
alberi sono bocca guardate un po quanto
sembra non era purtroppo scatti tra un
numero 3
allora dovrà decidere se tenerlo
scambiarlo io nello scambio 3 aspetta lo
tengo
321 sento perché non avete personaggio
questi sono quelli preferiti
l'ho letta anch'io un dolcetto o gelato
e 08 all'arancia bene
almeno mi lasci la sorpresa da un pezzo
di cioccolato perché sono buono una
piccola speriamo che qualcosa c'è ma
l'ultimo passaggio e l'altro questo nome
h24 con lo scambio grandi 14
l'odierno scambi boscardin
[Musica]
allora queste che potrebbero capitare
timpone ma potrebbero capitarti anche
disgustoso se avete visto il video degli
snack ha subito la mangiata quale cos'è
l'uomo ora ci rovinerà quindi realtà
viste caramel erano un po dolce tutto
rispetto
io però queste gomme da masticare che
che cosa il peccato allora io come
queste gomme da masticare perché me li
ricordo ha aggiunto
in pratica sono le gomme che ti invitano
trappola che intrappola nel dito tipo
troppo la partita impoverito pd come
trappola sì abbiamo un po avute due uno
scaffale olio buona celeron
l'oggetto un puntino balzare 11 come
morte al 25
tocca a me scegliere o cambiarlo ma
viene innescato da tutti a me lo tengo
321 cioccolato grande allora te capitata
il lo zucchero filato ha privato di ma
per dare altre la patente mi piaceva
tanto vediamo io ho qualcosa di sospetto
perché sembra un cioccolato kinder roma
dietro c'è qualcos'altro ed è stato
arrotolato male perché l'azione del
terzo anti questo club con del sangue da
mettere subito
guardate ora sembra che ho invito che lo
si sta 2
tito pieno di sangue ok il tango piano
di zuccheri out 69 portieri hanno scambi
l'omaggio quindi lo tiene ben 321 almeno
del mostro
ma scheletro vorresti cioccolato in area
sanchez
milano niente però tocca subito quindi
[Musica]
con troppi zuccheri cambiarlo non troppo
agitato lo scambio
allora 332 cancellino i tanti becca lo
scherzetto delle cancellino cancelliamo
io dico cancellino come dite cancellino
cancellino o bianchetto aperto come gli
si mattino spiega certe non promettiamo
di tutti i colori sbianchetto bianchetto
mia crisi anche grazie allo zucchero
filato offerte alla meno aperte e mi
piaceva questo veramente pieno piaceva
non è merito di questa volta imparate
che bello che bello parte che perde
corpo recente però mantenuta viva
[Musica]
se volete altri video così che mi
piacciono
guardatevi 5 si conciliano mamma mi ha
veramente guardate qui diventa quando
mangiato più zuccheri politeama di zona
si sentì male che non è vero
ok mi sono iscritto di questi reati con
la testa perché 13 non so che fine ha
fatto bene prima di me governarli cento
schematizzato più di stare tenuto allora
fateci sapere qual è lo scherzetto che
vi è piaciuto di più è il dolcetto che
mi è piaciuto di più quello che vorresti
mangiare o assaggiare
fatecelo sapere nei commenti e provate a
mettervi lato questo video con il naso e
ci riesce
sia che siate sul telefono
forse un computer o sul tavolo dai
computer per mettere tutto cosa spiega
perché non si lascia vedere un laico
rinato
e allora mi lasciavo fa quattro
cartellini e su cui cliccare per vedere
le nostre altre challenge i nostri video
divertenti cliccate su quella che
preferite
lo sapevamo ciao ciao